two high school basketball coaches are
facing murder charges following a
teenage athlete's death during an
outdoor practice sixteen-year-old amani
bell died in 2019 after collapsing
outside her atlanta area high school her
cause of death was heat stroke last
month a grand jury indicted her coaches
on multiple felonies including second
degree murder and cruelty to children in
the second degree mark strassman spoke
with imani's father who hopes the
charges lead to justice and safety for
other kids
imani bell was a high school junior with
dreams of going to stanford and a love
of basketball imani was a fantastic kid
daddy's girl mama's girl definitely
daddy's girl
definitely daddy's girl because
well we just had a special bond
eric bell's 16 year old daughter died
two years ago tomorrow after she
collapsed running the stairs of her high
school's football stadium her coaches
held the outdoor conditioning practice
despite a heat index of 103 degrees at
the hospital er doctors could not save
her
the doctors worked on it for about
about 45 minutes to hour and
body just couldn't take anymore it was
like keep working keep working he was
like
we can't it's
the body's not responding anymore
you actually watched your daughter die
yes i was in i was in the room i was
actually in the room
and uh you know that's just a memory
that i never forget
it's uh i replay it every day and
you know it's just kind of
it's tough
bell's autopsy found no underlying
medical issues she died of hyperthermia
heat stroke
the day she collapsed the actual
temperatures reached 97 degrees the
state's athletic regulations ban outdoor
workouts during any temperature above 92
degrees
and one hour before her practice her
school district sent a warning to all
schools no sports or clubs outside
eric bell is also a basketball coach and
you had a practice schedule that day yes
and you cancelled it canceled because it
was too hot outside at the end of the
day only one thing comes and that's to
get that child back home to their
parents
prosecutors blame bell's former coaches
larosa maria walker asakiri and dwight
palmer they face second-degree murder
charges every coach is now going to have
to think about imani bell
and the repercussions
of putting winning over life
the money bell was climbing stadium
stairs just like these in the heat
when she collapsed clayton county's
school district had no comment about
this case because of pending litigation
and we couldn't track down the lawyers
who represent the two charged coaches
but you can bet that coaches everywhere
who will work out athletes in the summer
heat today have heard about this case
tony yeah there are things more
important than practice and winning as
you said mark thank you very much